c'était la fin de marquer et c'est la
fin et à force de courir après plusieurs
lièvres à la fois notre ami greg gens
qui risquent de finir célibataire
c'était le vendredi
voilà c'était sa dernière chance
forcément pour greg c'est hors de
question de finir laventure célibataire
alors pour la dernière soirée grec tente
le tout pour le tout et fait une
déclaration d'amour à maeva maeva c'est
sa première 9 e bay s'est mis sur une
autre 9
malheureusement sa technique ne marche
pas comme ils voudraient vous dit ça
marche pas mais vous connaissez greg il
ne perd jamais la face
décidément c'est vraiment mon patron
fait le héros des temps modernes
regardez on le kif pour mon courage à
deux mains je la regarde dans les yeux
et îles fidji ce que je ressens est ce
que je pense tout simplement la première
fois que je t'ai regarder mon coeur a
succombé et je sais que ça avec toi que
je finirais je t'attends à tout jamais
pas de faux espoirs
mais rejetée par m pour m toi nistos
mytf1
[Applaudissements]
alors comme on vient de le voir donc le
progrès qui s'est pris un gros vent mais
pourtant la nuit qui suit maeva vient
quand même rejoindre greg dans son lit
curieuse méthode
alors est-ce que maeva est venu pour
s'excuser
est-ce que maeva est venu pour chercher
des câlins ou est-ce que maeva est venu
pour tout autre chose
je vous donne un indice visiblement pour
greg c'était pas son jour de chance les
gars des bons gars parce que c'est quand
même la forme de sa vie
et hier il a fait une petite déclaration
d'amour mais je pense que finalement
elle aime d'un grec mais pour finir dans
son lit à côté lui et je pense qu'ils
ont
[Musique]
je fais toute l'année j'ai trop de
choses l'attaqué touche x d'un canapé
est venu ici elle a juste vu un
moustique
là ils voulaient l'appliquer mais d'une
autre façon lui alors comme je vous le
disais la compétition les marseillais
contre le reste du monde c'est fini
et pour clôturer le jeu les candidats
font face à des épreuves de plus en plus
dû par exemple cette saison la
production a décidé de faire jouer des
marseillais à questions pour un champion
au alors on a bien vu des questions mais
je crois qu'on n'a pas vu les champions
autre action les filles qu est ce qu un
carré mauvaise réponse 5 reçu comme un
cumulus soulever oui oui ça où les
marseillais
comment s'appelle le petit du chameau
continue à jouer au congo continue à
jouer comme quel est le métier de super
mario d'amico et on se chie dessus un
esquimau à vingt trois chiens de
traîneau mais on perd cette convient de
chamirey de ce type
car la bnci à chier les gars maintenant
il ya une autre téléréalité qui va
arriver on va s'en occuper bien entendu
les génies du pas vous allez retrouver
tous les jours